so what was your first big break in the
show business American Pie great
character thank you love that movie
thank you I was working at Home Depot as
a plumber I lived in La for like three
years and no kidding and uh but she came
to LA to be an actor yeah but I I didn't
really know anything about it it was one
of the first comedies ever audition for
and I and I sucked and then um I think I
worked at Scientific Revolution selling
glowin the- dark stars I worked at
California Pizza Kitchen as a host and
and I didn't you know I think it was
getting better at auditions but I didn't
have any credits then I got the script
for American Pie and I was like the the
part was like two scenes long and um I
just knew I needed to get a part and so
I I called up all these kids that I went
to school with and uh cuz I was you know
I was kind of a nice guy and I was like
I have to do something different you
know to get this part and I took I
called up with all these guys and this
one guy was kind of a jerk to me but had
characteristics that I thought really
really interesting and I would just like
you know kind him a little bit yeah and
I went in and I fooled him I got the
part